The Beatles’ 1967 hit “Strawberry Fields
Forever” has long been considered one of
the greatest pop songs ever recorded.
Released in February of that year as a double
A side single along with Penny Lane, the song
peaked at number eight on the US Billboard
charts (The Turtles’ “Happy Together”
was number one that week).
In 2011, Rolling Stone named it the band’s
third greatest song and the 76th greatest
song ever.
Written by John Lennon, it’s a true masterpiece,
but what it isn’t is a song about fields
full of strawberries.
Reading the lyrics, it’s clear that the
song isn’t as happy-go-lucky as the melody
might suggest.
The song is more about Lennon’s insecurities
and his tough childhood.
The title of the song refers to the Salvation
Army-ran girl’s orphanage – dreamily called
“Strawberry Field” – that Lennon lived
near growing up in Liverpool.
Here’s the real story behind the song “Strawberry
Fields Forever.”
The Beatles were going through a rough patch
when they all splintered off in the summer
of 1966, immediately following what would
be their last US live performance at San Francisco’s
Candlestick Park.
The Fab Four would eventually reunite for
six more albums (and one legendary, unannounced
rooftop live performance), but that wasn’t
known in the summer of ‘66.
For his part, Lennon made his way to Almería,
Spain to star in the black comedy How I Won
the War.
With long waits between shooting scenes, Lennon
had plenty of time to write.
In six weeks, he had a working version of
the song that would come to define the Beatles’
second act.
John Lennon’s childhood wasn’t particularly
happy.
When he was a baby, his banjo-playing father
Alf was rarely home and often away at sea
as a merchant.
Tired of his travels, John’s mother Julia
fell in love with another man and got pregnant
with John’s half-sister.
This caused a tremendous rift in the Lennon
family with Julia’s sister Mimi calling
social services twice on her own sister for
raising John in, what she called, an unfit
home.
Eventually, social services handed John’s
care over to Aunt Mimi and he spent a large
portion of his childhood at his Aunt’s suburban
Liverpool home in a town called Woolton – the
house is now part of UK’s National Trust
as a museum.
John’s relationships with his parents after
that were tragic.
He wouldn’t see his father again for over
two decades.
John’s mother was hit and killed by a speeding
car while crossing a road when John was only
17.
According to Cynthia Lennon, John’s first
wife, while Aunt Mimi did care for John, “she
was not a woman for cuddles and praise.”
Ruling with an iron fist, John was expected
to be obedient, well-behaved and groomed.
Later, biographers would write that he had
a hard time making friends.
It’s little wonder that young John Lennon
had a rebellious streak and would often go
in secret to play in the gardens of his next
door neighbor – the girl’s orphanage Strawberry
Field.
StrawberryfieldThe history of Strawberry Field
dates back to 1870, when the property was
owned by a wealthy English ship owner named
George Warren.
On the site, he built a giant gothic mansion
that was in line with England’s Victorian-era,
complete with a iron wrought gate, gardens
and flowers.
In 1927, another wealthy ship magnate named
Alexander C. Mitchell purchased the mansion
and property.
Seven years later, Mitchell’s widow sold
it to the Salvation Army.
On July 7, 1936, the home was opened as a
orphanage for up to forty girls.
Two decades later, boys would be allowed in,
but throughout most of John’s childhood,
Strawberry Field was an all-girls’ orphanage.
Years later, interviews would reveal the influence
this foreboding, mysterious place had on Lennon’s
writing.
In a 1968 Rolling Stone interview, Lennon
said that he was trying to write about Liverpool
and had “visions of Strawberry Fields…
Because Strawberry Fields is just anywhere
you want to go.”
(Note that the song title is “Strawberry
Fields,” but the actual place is called
“Strawberry Field.”
Lennon would later admit that this was a stylistic
choice- “Fields” simply sounded better
than “Field.”)
Lennon also often alluded to how Strawberry
Field was representative of his childhood,
on the outside foreboding but once he climbed
over that wall, full of wildflowers and secretive
gardens.
It’s also thought that he greatly identified
with the orphans who lived there, considering
that he felt abandoned by his parents.
In 1980, he explained his childhood thinking,
“There was something wrong with me, I thought,
because I seemed to see things other people
didn’t see.”
When John Lennon brought the song back to
the band in November of 1966, it was met with
awe.
Engineer Geoff Emerick recalled to Rolling
Stone that fateful moment, “There was a
moment of stunned silence, broken by Paul,
who in a quiet, respectful tone said simply,
‘That is absolutely brilliant.’”
Over about a month, the band tinkered and
recorded the song.
It is widely thought of as the most complicated
recording the Beatles ever did.
When it was released in February of 1967,
it was exactly what McCartney said when he
first heard the song John Lennon named after
a Liverpool girl’s orphanage – brilliant.
Today, Strawberry Field is in a state of disrepair
despite continuing to be a tourist attraction
for Beatle fanatics.
In 2005, after nearly 70 years as an orphanage,
it closed down and all the remaining children
were transferred to foster families.
While many of the original buildings and structures
were torn down in the 1970s, a few still remained
including the iconic red Victorian-era Strawberry
Field gates – until 2001.
The gates, which dated back to Warren, were
put into storage and replaced with replicas,
leaving many fans (and tour guides, who rely
on Beatle-related income) upset.
Plans were announced in 2014 to turn the site
into “a training centre for people with
learning difficulties” along with a museum
and artifacts dedicated to the influence this
place had on the Beatles and John Lennon.
However, as of this writing, Strawberry Field
remains abandoned and mostly decrepit.